rocking the headphones today look at
that yeah yeah no no choice i'm uh i'm
kind of stuck in a little nook because
uh
i i my internet was turned off by some
error from rogers so i'm stealing or
borrowing internet from my neighbor so i
had to move myself to a corner
no
yeah yeah he does i have to get his
password oh okay it's been like this for
like four days now oh very good turned
on today yeah wow dude we got to get
that fixed man i know oh that's what i
was telling them but they're not in a
rush so
all right so welcome everybody we are
live with uh
rich again talking about his inspire
movement this is our
second episode helping him lead his
charge so what's been going on the last
time we spoke was april 17th so so
pretty much a month ago yeah that was
our first call it's been a fun month man
yeah it has it's been exciting
so give an update what's going on so so
far i have uh i've started
the inspire movement what you told me to
do what you uh
i've got the quotes out with the images
worked that out i've
put one out every monday and friday as
prescribed
and i've got the first video i did with
you is out and i've got a few more on
the way now so i didn't release anything
yesterday because i just didn't have
enough power for bandwidth to put it up
but next wednesday i will
so other than that i just streamlined a
few of the
the images and videos for posting i've
streamlined that i think i got a handle
on that now okay i'm ready i'm ready for
the next challenge some of them have
been great man um
i mean i've i post them i've been
sharing them on my stuff too they're
getting some great feedback that i think
the stunning one did the best the
running one yeah oh really amazing
they're running on different mediums i
think facebook the running one did the
best um
what was the first one it was was it
partnered with shallows the first one
was cardinal official uh the criticism
one do nothing be nothing yeah uh the
the running one didn't do much on my
facebook well i don't have much action
on my facebook now anyways because i
don't use it that much but uh
the one that really did a lot for me was
by virtue of who was in the photo was uh
the one with uh the calisthenics there
um what was it
the one with the guy doing a push-up in
the air oh yeah
yeah yeah
um i figured what the quote was uh
don't let the people tell you yeah
the one who says it cannot be done must
not interrupt when the one who's doing
it something yeah
good
that's good man i like it i like it and
the most recent one was your son right
yeah the most first one is my son yeah
it's a funny photo you know my my wife
didn't want me to put it out because
it's kind of like it's a funny looking
photo of our boy but i just thought it
was really funny because he looks like
an old man and he's got this dummy look
on like
like you're a dummy i'm a dummy that
kind of looks i thought that that i
thought that was really nice
wide open man the idea yeah yeah yeah i
have a blow up of that as well i like it
it makes me laugh okay so
uh we talked about the pictures putting
your own
quotes
yeah so once a week was your own quote
once week was gonna be somebody else's
quote
yeah and then there's gonna be a video
per week right yeah so the quotes so far
they've all been you right
pretty much uh it might be in my shop it
might be some quote i really liked
before but i may have put my own
interpretation on it okay some of them
i've been collecting stuff for years so
i don't even remember where stuff is
from most of the time if it's from
someone i'll put down below it okay this
guy wrote or that guy wrote it or this
girl uh so but for these ones there's no
uh
no signature so it might have been me it
might have been a mashup i don't know
okay
you know it's good to uh
it's good to attribute
right like if you know there's a quote
from somebody
you put their name on it because people
will
especially as a recognizable name to
people well that helps spread it so it's
not just you being the thought leader
you're also sharing other people's stuff
if it's
you know oprah or whoever yeah you know
you're inspired by um so that would that
would be great to see right okay one
quote a week with your
thoughts your quotes even it's a mashup
whatever like your spin on it that's
cool that's the vibe we're going with
maybe that's the monday one and then the
friday one is an actual quote and you
know you pop their name into the
into the picture itself
underneath
um
just for the variety so it's not just
all the same thing coming out yeah that
sounds good um okay great and then the
video so
the first one went up with me
and then you're gonna what's happening
on the next wednesdays though
on the next
the other ones or what are you gonna do
you know what uh i have another
interview ready
i just have to upload it so i wasn't
sure if it was gonna be another
interview now i'm just trying to think
long term how i'm gonna be able to keep
it up in terms of content i need to have
uh other content as well that i don't
necessarily create
if in order for me to be able to
maintain four video posts a month yeah
right so um
but i like your idea of finding stuff
that inspires me that i like and and
putting that out on on wednesday that's
something i should i could do right or
should yeah i'm just going to write
something down because i got an idea i
don't want to lose it
yeah
you know you start talking and you lose
ideas
okay
um
so there's a few options for you
i i service things from my channel i
just
released a video of me in malaysia doing
my speech a little workshop in malaysia
and finding your one word and
um
it's like over 12 minutes long so i know
the one you did with me was like half an
hour or something yeah so i released
that and then like we talked about i
released one minute
even the first was like 45 seconds up to
three minute clips so i broke that 12
minutes down into
individual clips not a promo not like
hey go check out this interview but
within that minute i'm saying a complete
thought
right so like in our in our interview i
mean i'm sure it happens with all the
other ones
we talked about a whole bunch of
different stuff
right
so it's
there's a lot of different individual
segments that you can break out of it
now
if you want to share that on your
channel or if you want to share it on my
channel just for a promotional boost i'm
happy to go either way or you can split
like maybe three go online and it's a
long interview man
you know three go on mine and ten go on
yours right but that's how you take so
you have your full interview
and then you have
these little clips these micro clips
that are a minute to three minutes long
so that that one interview might give
you 20 micro clips that you can use for
the next 20 weeks
or 10.
20 maybe a little too long but but 10 is
doable
that makes sense
keep your video content going and on my
channel
this is this is what happens the the
micro ones
are doing just as well if not better
than the full one
but it's a different audience see the
micro ones brings in new people
and then the people who become hardcore
they want to go watch the full one
right so they make the micro clip of
your interview with me it's like oh
that's really cool you know i want to
learn more and then boom below was the
full interview that they can watch
at their leisure so that's how you
stretch out the content a little bit
more
okay
uh i got a question from somebody
watching chefs tv
is this a video for you and your fans i
didn't get started just joined in so
this is the rich richest theme is
inspire he wants to inspire people to
live their best lives and i am coaching
him to help him along that process so
he's got some videos rich what's plug
your youtube channel what's what's your
youtube channel
uh
you know uh it's under you gotta love
i'm not sure what the short code is
right now it's just a whole bunch of
numbers
but uh
if you search my name richard you gotta
love you'll find it that way
uh how do i get it to have youtube
forward slash you gotta love it yeah you
know what you get
you get invited so
yeah so um i'm getting invited yet yeah
yeah well it's coming man it's coming
it's coming it's coming uh so you've got
a lot of y-o-u gotta
g-o-g-o-t-t-a l-o-v-e
yeah you typing you gotta love you'll
find it
so
so that's that's one easy way to do it i
know you have a few interviews coming up
you haven't released yet
another easy way to do it is you pull in
clips that you
like for whatever reason right but
another one you know what the feedback
that i got from the video
from a number of different people who i
respect from our interview because i i
shared it even though
i think it's in my playlist on my
channel people wanted to know about you
oh
like who's interviewing you
and even even just um
like the questions as you ask them you
put them up as text yeah
where they said you know would be cool
even just to hear his voice
that's
next level uh comfort zone that's next
level but i mean so you're not on camera
i mean that could be the next level too
but uh
there's a there's a curiosity and an
interest
okay and so
something to think about
for your next video that you know you're
producing um i mean ideally you're even
on camera even for a little bit to say
hey it's rich i'm sitting with uh evan
and today we're talking about blah blah
blah and then he's still like whoever
you're even still the star of the show
that's cool i know you're not like hey
i'm in the limelight look at me i know
that's not your
your style but
if people can make a personal connection
to you
they're more likely to feel closely
connected to inspire and want to follow
you and retweet your stuff and share it
so like your your picture isn't anywhere
right you're not in any
the stuff you post your face is
sometimes there like as the as the icon
right okay but
you're not in any of your stuff
no i'm not and people are asking like
it'd be cool to see the interaction
where is this guy i want to know who
this guy is
okay so
um that's exciting
it's good but yeah consistently that
came back from a number of different
people i said hey check out this video
interview i did and and by the way like
rave reviews about the
the quality of the
imagery and how beautiful the setup and
everything looks is that right yeah yeah
like they say hey that's the best video
you've ever shot evan
i'm glad they like it it took me a part
of the reason it took me so long to
release the first video was because i
was working through
all that stuff the visuals because i
wanted to do it a certain way
that is not normal because you know you
know who does black and white and all
these like i deliberately destroyed the
look of some of the video to make it
look kind of kind of used up and old
except that one camera looked really
nice real clean so i'm glad they like it
that's great because that's the
direction i'm going with all of them
yeah it looked good so so that was great
feedback consistently so the other so
again obviously they want you in it
somehow even for your voice
um
the other one the other feedback that
came back from a few people was uh
they would love to see more than just
me
on camera
so if it if it cuts to and maybe this
can work into your future ones but it
cuts to
um even like i
you know you have b b was it b-roll
b-roll yeah like you're doing stuff so
the interviews with you you're doing
stuff like you don't have been done
before if i'm talking about
uh i don't know if i talked about a
famous entrepreneur i probably did
right if i'm talking about steve jobs
show steve
jobs cut to something else and then cut
back to me or if at any time they're
telling stories a lot of people will
tell like they'll tell their own story
but they'll tell
so if i'm saying hey you know i'm born
and raised in toronto canada i love my
city toronto
you flash up the cn tower i mean i don't
want to mess with your style yeah you
know what you're doing but that was just
feedback that came back from a couple
people too to say hey it'd be great to
mix in some other things besides just
seeing
yeah the whole time so just to think
about and if i do that how is that going
to affect video via youtube because it's
uh copywritten content
um it's okay as long as you're not part
of the advertising program
okay
unless
so the only situation where it's not is
if they
uh whoever owns the rights contacts you
and says shut it down okay guys it
doesn't happen that often though like
you see it a lot even you look at any um
any any song like you look at lady
gaga's song there's a whole bunch of
other videos that are out there with
just the lyrics on it yeah the lyrics
right
people reuse that stuff over and over
and over and over again but you don't
qualify for the uh advertising program
okay that's nothing to be concerned
about yes
you'll get a notice saying hey this is
recognized third-party content you
acknowledge
and you say yes
okay and that's it okay great um
yeah so maybe that was your concern i
don't know but um yeah anyway
i could spice it up with some music
because i wanted to put some music in
the backdrop make it more interesting
more dramatic but yeah yeah yeah
yeah now youtube gives you
some music options but it's limited i'm
sure you have your own you know you have
your own style and
pick your own stuff yeah um
good so
so
for the video you have your full length
you have your short clips
broken down from that video you have
other clips that you like
to share like if it's a steve jobs
inspirational speech or something
um and then the other one that this is
going to be the the hardest one for you
the biggest you know next level
challenge is is you
saying something like rich on camera
right on camera yeah recon camera
talking about
a story like make it personal to me like
it's great to see these other people's
stories but the more you do that
people are going to want to ask hey rich
man what's your story why are you doing
this great stuff
um this is what happened to me with my
site
so
my website used to be all about famous
entrepreneurs
because i found that their stories
inspire and i felt hey you know what i
learned from you guys i want other
entrepreneurs to learn from them it's
all about them it's not about me
learn from the famous entrepreneurs and
then as it got more popular people
started asking hey evan like we want to
know like who's this guy who created
this resource want to know about you
and so i
really really like over years
reluctantly started sharing stuff more
and more and more and more but the more
i did that the faster everything grew
because there's a faith there's a
personal connection people feel that i
care um
and so they're bonded to it more tightly
so
you're going to look at the stuff you
make and say wow i suck on camera that
was brutal you know it takes a lot of it
will take a lot of time and practice and
effort but that's kind of
you have to worry about it maybe quite
yet but that's kind of next level
maybe gear some thinking towards it okay
what message can rich
share about
inspire
and it doesn't have to be too
thought out or complex right like raw
original stuff is good even you walking
on the street
right i think you think back to our uh
when we had that campfire
right at the lake house and and we're
hashing out some ideas
right like even coming out of that if
you're in an inspired moment
just take a quick
you know take your phone out and record
it
and have that as a message for people to
to digest so if i i know you're like
kicking it in but you're like no man no
no i'm not doing that come on you're
crazy
when i feel that burning desire you know
and i have to do it you know when
someone's yeah it'll happen
at times right it happened in your life
you see something you see somebody
taking action that's not inspired or
something upsets you you know you can
put a you can put an inspire
angle on a lot of things that happen in
your daily life
um okay it doesn't have to be like hey
rich's personal blog and everyday
you know yeah
the rich but to add that in once a month
kind of thing
okay awesome flavor in there
a small question i don't know if this is
relevant or not but let me know with the
whole hashtag inspired versus hashtag
inspire and evolution is one better than
the other is our point because hashtag
inspire is so huge and vast i'm not
trying to win on that am i
uh
well it depends what win is see you have
your own spin on it right believe
is
it means a lot of things a lot of people
right like for a lot of people believe
is a religious thing right i believe in
god right
that's cool that's just not that's not
my angle on it right so you're putting
your own definition on it but you have
your one word so inspire
comes through you you look at the stuff
that that you're promoting out there
right we asked we talked last time
they'll come up with the three main
ideas at the beginning
did you finish that
i did not but uh i will this week
all right on my um
so it's still inspired but it's your
definition of it right so
evolution
is part of it
the
fun
is part of it right
um
what was the other thing like being
different or the rebel
side of it right all your stuff
blends in
yeah
okay
um the other thought i had for you
and this takes i don't know if you're
quite ready for it yet but
recognizing
people who you think are doing a good
job already that are on the same path
with you as on this inspiration
journey right so
a great thing that i do that's had a lot
of impact on on twitter is every day i
recognize what i call a small business
champion of the day
and it'll be like small business
champion of the day and they'll pull in
somebody who i think is doing a great
job doing they may be well known you
know it may be somebody from the
dragon's den or shark tank and it's in
hey i'm just recognizing you guys
because i think what you're doing is
important
or maybe
it may be something uh
someone that nobody's ever heard of
but i think they're doing a great job
and so what it does is now you're
reaching out to people who some you know
some of you don't know and you're just
giving them praise and recognition
they're gonna check out your channel
right they're gonna check out your your
twitter
stream and see what you're posting so
that's why you need to be consistent
with your
pictures and your videos because you
want them to see what you're putting up
there and say wow this rich that's some
cool stuff i'm gonna i'm gonna follow
him i'm gonna start sharing this stuff
too
okay
we got a comment from one of our viewer
chefs tv who wrote in to say it'd be
easier to recognize if you go with
inspire
okay hashtag inspire chefs is a fan
all right it's good sounds good
we got we got the fans tuning in
watching out actually i think chefs just
wrote into me recently it was uh his one
word is revolutionary so
not that far off from what you believe
in too so yeah yes you should be
following you gotta love on twitter and
check out his stuff
that's good okay so
so looking at the next couple weeks
we've got our monday is gonna be the
richie quotes friday's going to be the
famous quotes or at least a recognized
yeah somebody else somebody else's quote
and then wednesday is going to be
a video either a full-length video or
clips yeah is that
feasible doable manageable yeah that
totally is totally is but is that it or
is there something more it should be
uh
well if you want to jump
the next the next two things are
recognizing the people
right
so you have your champion of the week
for inspire
and you start getting on video yourself
too
getting on video so that's the next step
that that is a good next step but it's
going to be a while to make that perfect
but really what you need to do is get
your
your system
regular
you're pretty close like you're you've
been doing it right it's been for what
three weeks now has it been
summer and we're this is the third week
now
i believe it is the third week yeah
yeah so consistent right and how are you
getting you getting some feedback on any
of the stuff you're putting up
uh
yeah i've been getting a few comments
here and there and some likes
uh on facebook because where i see
where i see uh most of our activities on
facebook i i haven't still haven't been
able to figure out everything with
twitter and g plus and all that you know
how to keep on top of everything without
wasting hours and hours so that that's
kind of one of my handicaps with the
social media stuff is how do i get the
relevant information and you know go in
get the info go out i don't want to be
stuck there for hours and hours
um
right
what's that you're using your blog to
post to yeah everything's going via the
blog right so except the videos the
videos don't work well yeah the videos i
have to do one by one as you as you uh
said so i just put it on
post it personally on each one of them
yeah with the videos actually you
there's an option with um on youtube
itself
so part of what we'll do is you can
schedule when a video gets released
right
okay you know that
uh yeah you mentioned that but i've
never looked into how to do it yet okay
so this this would be helpful you go to
uh when you upload a video you're given
options
and
one of the options is scheduled
okay
and so we schedule our videos to go out
every day i do two a day so it's uh what
is it two o'clock every day and i think
nine o'clock
every night
something like that
so it's automatically scheduled and you
pick the day so you can say okay next
wednesday two o'clock boom this video is
coming the following wednesday boom so
you can upload them all at once
schedule the time
and then
on the upload screen is a sharing option
so once you upload it you click the
schedule
uh you can share it to twitter and
facebook
and google plus
facebook
i think facebook only goes to your um
personal though not to your fan page
okay
so
there's a there's a solution around that
too but um
so it'll automatically post this is how
i post to twitter and google plus
so i just post it to youtube
and it goes up automatically to
twitter and google plus whenever it
launches at two o'clock or nine o'clock
at night okay
okay
okay
so that that'll save some time because
you can batch them all you make them all
put them up
you know for the next two months here
are the eight videos that are going live
and they'll automatically go to twitter
and uh
and google plus that's a good idea
for facebook i use uh a program called
buffer app
uh okay have you used buffer ever told
you about this
yeah you told me about buff rap but i
wasn't sure
i mean it seemed redundant with the the
plugin you have for the website yeah so
this is this is how i get the videos to
go to
my facebook
fan page okay so you set a rule that
anything that comes from
uh
youtube so once we post a youtube video
it posts it to the facebook page
okay
buck wrap you can do it through
um if this than that it's
ifttt.com
either of them work but basically
once you set up all the systems
you're posting your pictures on your
blog and you're posting the videos on
youtube and scheduling them you schedule
it on your blog you schedule it on
youtube those are your two homes
and then everything else takes care of
itself so you don't have to log in each
time to all the different networks
that takes a lot of time
okay
so you know once i
post the videos and the images know that
um
what's the best way to kind of to get
action with it all though i mean if
people are liking it or commenting on it
i mean is there a way for me to start
interacting with them or just kind of
let it grow for now
uh so the combination right like when i
post something of yours on my channel
i get way more reaction than you do it's
the same
content but just because i have a larger
audience so that's fine that's how it
starts so consistently posting good
stuff will start getting people
talking about you okay but then on top
of that anytime somebody is interacting
with your stuff
thank them and reach out
okay so if somebody retweets you
thank you okay thanks for the retweet if
somebody
comments on it
leave a comment back like it's a lot of
work for me
every day i wake up when i start
responding to youtube comments it's
crazy
it's crazy how many comments on social
media between youtube and twitter and
everything i get
probably around 100 comments
and that's my morning i'm eating my
lentils
like comments responding and some of
them aren't okay it's not like the most
uh
insightful it may just be like hey
thanks for watching rich
but they feel recognized and so they're
more likely to come back
and watch another one and another one
another one and share them
okay so that's
so it's one consistency keep posting
this stuff on your schedule people will
get used to it
so that's one number two
people who are sharing and interacting
with it you want to recognize them you
can get notifications either by email or
whatever is i get my youtube comments
emailed to me on youtube
and then i use hootsuite for my
twitter but do whatever
it's best and then three start using the
people
who you're interviewing
right so
if you want to post some of those videos
on my channel i'll do it for you right
so it gives you exposure i'm already
sharing your pictures
and you know keeping the inspire and
you've got a lot starting to generate if
i do that consistently too then it's
going to get more people typing and
you've got to love them
um but that's that's that's the start
uh i got a question from somebody
watching what's your twitter name i want
to follow you
oh thank you you got a love
everything is you gotta love you gotta
love it
the words yeah just at u y-o-u
gotta g-o-t-t-a
love
hello v yeah yeah l-o-v-e
and uh and you'll find rich
good
man another month down i'm excited
yeah me too so are we going to do this
you're going to send me some videos
i will send you some videos i will send
you some videos
i've been having some hard time with my
computer is a little bit uh like an old
dog you know it's huffing and puffing
but i figured out ways to
to make it work with me okay so i've got
a few videos ready and i know i was
supposed to get some clips to you and
i'll get them to you uh over the weekend
okay cool yeah i mean it's not a russian
mayan i just need to schedule yeah you
know it's a rush in my end it just you
know you know how things happen i have
i'm saying it more for myself than for
you to remind myself good love it all
right thanks rich have a great month
we'll talk to everyone
and uh keep up on email if you have
questions perfect thank you very much
cheers